passenger rights groups say smaller
airline seat space could put travelers
at risk in an emergency evacuation
the FAA argued in federal appeals court
that shrinking seat space in coach does
not present a threat to health or safety
but the judges disagreed they ordered
the FAA to reevaluate its standards Kris
Van Cleave as at Reagan National Airport
outside Washington Chris good morning
well good morning the manufacturers that
build airplanes have to certify that
they can get everyone off a completely
full airliner within 90 seconds even
with half of the exit blocked that 90
second rule is based on the idea that's
enough time to get people off before
fire smoke or water could turn an
accident deadly but evacuations don't
always go smoothly last fall this
American 767 had to evacuate after an
engine caught fire during takeoff in
Chicago our board passengers pushed and
shoved to get out some stopped to grab
their luggage
it took 116 passengers and nine crew
more than two minutes to get off Hector
Cardenas was on that flight and captured
the mayhem on his phone
everyone's shoving and pushing against
you in such a way where you're pretty
much almost squashed passengers safety
advocates worry the ever-shrinking
airline seat is creating another
potential danger during an evacuation
just as the passengers themselves are
getting bigger the space between rows
has shrunk from as much as 35 inches to
31 sometimes down to just 28 the biggest
fear is that people won't be able to get
out in time Paul Hudson is president of
Flyers rights an advocacy group that
sued to force the FAA to regulate seat
size they claim that they have no
jurisdiction over comfort so but isn't
it safety well they view safety very
narrowly a federal court agreed there
was the possibility of plausible life or
death issues the FAA says it is
reviewing the ruling it's a true safety
problem and the FAA needs to protect us
Congressman Steve Cohen introduced
legislation to require the FAA to
establish a minimum airline seat size we
have seats and and aisles that are
capable of facilitating a safe exit the
group that represents u.s. Airlines says
its members meet or exceed federal
safety standards and airlines do train
for evacuations Boeing tells CBS this
morning that it conducts its evacuation
tests in full accordance with all
federal regulations but that's typically
done in a hangar and it doesn't factor
in passenger behavior like grabbing bags
gail yeah that's a very good point Chris
let's hope that safety Trump's that the
FAA is paying attention mm-hmm I thought
he made a very compelling case thank you
very much Chris Van Cleve